welcome to this video playing Grand
Master's I walk out someone crawled in
from Germany grammas a cheap shot I have
a number of games against him already
here in the King xenian playing a very
aggressive chest a six think I should
you find this riot c5 g5g five Bishop d3
if i'm not mistaken so he's preparing
that maybe let's see 92 in protects
eform yet another time and maybe he can
play with see 6b five now and then the
night is not such a great PCM ok but
still at some playable ok pepino nice
town should I play for maybe mmm I don't
know it shouldn't be a bad benoni mm2
III yawn yeah problem each form looks a
bit offside
yeah how do I play him it's not really
quickly going to get bigger counterplay
I don't don't think so maybe you will
see one with the idea to play B form the
right moment
I have a good control over c4n p5 let's
see i have a 50-percent score against
him by the way so and i'm not like
shaking here because of his big rating
um before you before takes 9 p-5 this
was the a gem okay so he's playing it
like that i can go be five now setting
up this night c4 blockade maybe maybe
just do that that's simple but probably
good and now F for em I need to get some
some play on the kingside take here and
94 or directly rook takes is also
interesting with Queen f1 here maybe I'm
Queen f1 Queen f1 f2 with us this this
type of maneuver
hmm interesting can I go Luke h4 then
take H 627 maybe
if I gunite c4 yeah probably really
should do that right and getting getting
rid of this piece only five it's just a
very strong night so take them Bishop
takes and I don't really have a good
square for the rook hmm
okay let's let's do that I don't really
mind if he takes this on therefore I
mean this must be compensation may be
queen here so that I can play book h
form if it takes it okay nothing to be
done about it yeah I expected that a
good dynamic player does not does not
like to give up this Bishop here okay so
he's attacking a form each for when I
bishops III maybe and 94 then all my
rooks are hanging that's not good
yeah not to move I want to play as
possibly bishop age three but nothing I
can do about it I need to get the night
out of this I know you can take but this
at least opens up the position time
warning to see what if you're here maybe
now that there are many technical tricks
yeah this is the problem like Queen edge
493 check if I would be able to get the
Korean yes King it does so would be an
interesting position okay it moves the
night now Queen g3 is quite nice maybe
it's still not so clear it's not like
he's having a good King position check
check
my ideas to to play with Queen DC's
maybe I'll bishop age six at the right
moment and then a double check I can
give the check now but it's nothing
nothing grade taking also it's not doing
me much good
check yeah the only thing that I can
only like a couple of chicks sure okay
white forfeits on time jump very very
very difficult game around here I'm I'm
of course very much better but it's very
difficult to play maybe look at four is
the mistake I don't know it also plus
1.5 444 stockfish it's clear black it's
just full of weaknesses and i have c
form here Scotty five though it's it's
very difficult to play maybe this one I
don't know it is it is difficult young
knight c for light XD five you always
want to take this take this take this
piece but the computer is so is really
advocating to play Queenie one here
Queenie one and of course he wants to
take with the bishop yeah maybe the
natural looking move was just the better
move it is better and it's mostly
because of Queenie one Queen g3 and
Queen to h4 may be the right moment this
is the computers line plus 21 look
everyone coming this is however very
difficult to play it now in a in a blitz
game it's not not an easy position to
play it's something that it would be
terrible in a in a tournament game then
then he will probably get completely
wiped out but here so it's difficult
with no time
baggage for I don't know I was hoping
that that that bishops III isn't great
he didn't do they played f5 and around
here I'm problem I probably don't have
any on ig6 now is good yeah just wins
back the exchange okay yeah I didn't
have much time 96 again that's good
check and here I'm losing yeah okay i
only had very little time on the clock
the whole the whole line here looks this
this looks extremely questionable for
black I mean this these moves are really
not any good I wonder what F force is
strong strong what i did i just wonder
can i maybe prepare it is this an idea
something like that with f40 I is this
idea okay then I must play G for him
okay that's not good alright thanks for
watching